It's great to be joined today by Michael Lynch,
who's the director of the humanities institute,
a professor
philosophy at the University of Connecticut.
Also author of the new book.
No at all society, truth and arrogance in
political culture.
Uh, Michael, so great to talk to you.
Thanks so much for having me.
This is such an interesting topic, a to me,
the idea of the sort of combination of a much
longer period of pseudo and anti intellectual
realism, which has sort of combined with or
crashed with this intellectual arrogance trend
that we're seeing partially because of the
Internet and social media.
Can you first just talk a little bit about
what are some of the ways that Internet and
social media have made people intellectually
arrogant?
Well, when we talk about, first of all, just,
you know, when we talk about intellectual
arrogance, what I mean is the idea of being
resistant to improving your worldview by appeal
to evidence or to the experience of other
people.
Uh, it's the idea that, you know, you know,
it all and that your, your, your worldview
is at least with some respects unimprovable
and I think there are pretty obvious ways
that all of us are, are really intimately
familiar with, uh, in which the Internet and
the ways in which we use the Internet can
reinforce and encourage this attitude.
I mean, for one thing, you know, no matter
what your opinion you may have on, on any
topic, you can Google and get some confirmation
for that opinion from some corner of the internet
or not.
Uh, and in a way, you know, right now, uh,
it used to be that scene was believing we'd
say, but now googling is believing and therefore,
and you know, getting information, uh, in
that way, the, the sort of weird, paradoxical
fact is that our ability to get information
in the, in that way so easily, right at our
fingertips is also, uh, not, not just making
us in a sense, feel more knowledgeable, but
feel that we, we are, uh, always right.
Because of, uh, the ability to confirm my
biases.
I mean, one add, one other element to that,
which is that the Internet is a personal personalized
information seeking device.
Uh, as it were, a set of devices and platforms.
Uh, everything that we encounter on the Internet,
uh, from the news that comes down, uh, our
Facebook feed to, uh, the ads that we see
on the pages we visit are all personalized.
And of course that's great when, uh, we're
shopping for books or shoes or what have you.
It's not so great when we're shopping for
facts because if you're just getting the facts
that confirm your preexisting prejudices,
that's a, you know, short road to type of
epistemic disaster.
Yeah.
There are some elements to the social media
platforms, the way you're talking about algorithmically
and otherwise, which sort of, um, encourage
or perpetuate a sort of reasoning from emotion
and style rather than facts.
But, but beyond that, is there something about
social media and the Internet that just beyond
the algorithms does encourage people to be
arguing more from emotion rather than from
fact?
Yeah, I think there is.
I think that one of the things that we, uh,
besides the sort of algorithms and the personalization,
one of the things that I think is really motivating
this rise that we see in a type of arrogance
and including what I would call as type of
tribal arrogance, is that we're often unaware
of how we're communicating on social media.
Um, we're sort of in a sense a blind to, to
the real nature of our communicative acts.
Here's an example.
When you share, when we all share something
online that's a news story, whether it's fake
or otherwise, when we share some piece of
news content, uh, you know, from the Guardian
or, or from this show or what have you, you
think of yourself, uh, as at least I do as
like sharing some piece of, you know, factual
information or at least saying, you know,
here's some interesting opinion that you should
probably pay attention to.
And I'm saying that to my, my friends or followers.
Yeah.
So it looks like I'm engaging in sort of the
game of, you know, giving reasons and so forth.
But really it seems like we might be doing
something else.
So one reason to think that is because a lot
of data's coming out right now, uh, that show
that something that we probably all intuitively
know, which is that almost no one that shares
things online reads what they share and what,
you know, what that, that so just something,
it's just that we're really not, we're doing
something else.
We're communicating in some other way.
And what I think we're often doing is what,
what we're doing is signaling that, well,
we're a member of a particular tribe or group.
We're saying we're on this team and we're
so we're, and we're communicating.
In other words, I sort of emotional feeling
and, or perhaps we're communicating in a sense
of outrage.
And of course the platforms are hardwired
to encourage this sort of thing.
The sorts of, uh, you know, the treats, again,
things that most of the people listening here
are going to know is that the more sort of
emotional language you include in your tweet
or your post, uh, the more sort of at language
of outrage who include the higher the likelihood
that that will be reposted, reshare, reshared
or retweet it.
And that fact alone suggests that the whole
economy of social media is, uh, encouraging
us to engage in this, uh, sort of expression
of sentiment.
I was David Hume, the philosopher would call
it a door emotion.
And the fact that we're not aware that we're
actually doing that makes us really easy marks.
Yeah.
Well, this, this starts being dovetail with,
um, findings from such, you know, varied academic
disciplines as what Jonathan Height has written
about in moral psychology.
What Daniel economen has written about in
behavioral economics that in many times we
simply, we believe that we have come to our
conclusions based on the evidence.
When in reality, we've often come to our conclusions
for other reasons.
Hight would say it relates to our moral values
that, that resonate more with us.
Uh, Daniel condiment would have more of a
logistical, practical behavioral economics
approach, but that we are first coming to
our conclusions then finding information to
justify them.
And that's where I think social media has
really scaled up this mechanism.
Yeah, it's a, it's, it's definitely a, a device,
a mechanism as you just said, uh, to fuel
confirmation bias.
I mean there's been a lot of research as,
as most of the listeners will probably know,
uh, about this sort of bubbles, the uh, information
and epistemic bubbles that we live in that
is, uh, fueled by the personalization we talked
about and also, uh, encouraged by the, the,
the, the hard wiring of the platforms as I
was talking about, uh, them to encourage the
emotional exchange over informational exchange.
I mean, I think what we're finding is that
both the economy of social media and our,
our, our psychology, our human psychology,
our PR, our just to working together and formed
me to sort of toxic mix that's include increasing
this type of arrogance that we're talking
about.
And of course you have to add to that politics
ideology.
Right now in our country, there is an increasing,
there are ideologies that are starting to
celebrate the idea that fat, uh, facts and
unreason and the experts and science celebrate
that those things should not be listened to
and that you should trust your gut and that
you should trust your child and that it's
the tribe that gives power and it's not, and
we're not answerable to the facts that, that
ideology together with the psychology that
we've already, we were just talking about.
And, uh, the, the technology that's a real
toxic mix and it's really leading to what
I'm calling the know-it-alls society.
So that's what I wanted to talk about next,
which is what do we know empirically, uh,
or, or a quantitatively about the partisan
divide on some of these phenomena.
Because, for example, there are many reports
which say if you look back at the 2016 election,
the amount of actual fake news, not using
the definition of the current president but
actual just straight rate fake news that was
shared was significantly higher by conservatives
than by liberals as one example of showing
that this phenomenon is not sort of taking
root equally across partisanship.
What can you add to our understanding of the
partisan element to this, uh, sort of cultural
element that you've identified?
The no, it all society.
Okay.
Well, you know, when we think about polarization,
so let's step back a little bit and think
about, uh, what, you know, common topic of
conversation conversations like this, which
is that, uh, you know, were polarized.
W recent data for example, from Pew, suggest
that on a broad range of issues, uh, uh, on,
on actual issues, if you pull people, uh,
who are both conservative leaning, conservative,
liberal, leaning and liberal, you find, surprisingly,
while of course Americans are, you know, strongly
divided on a whole number of issues, there's
actually much more agreement than you might
Annecy Lee think.
Yes.
At the same time, at the same time, there
is increasingly a dramatic increase in polarization
of what we might call effective polarization
polarization or, uh, group polarization.
That is, we are more and more prone to describe
the people on the other side of the aisle
as distrustful, as, as, as untrustworthy,
as a moral, as ignorant.
Uh, and we increasingly know that the other
side describes us.
Whoever the up us is in the same way, and
we resent them for it.
That, so the first thing I think to keep in
mind is that there's a sort of, hi, there's
a growing awareness that we, uh, that we are
sort of, uh, polarized in this way and there's,
I've strong resentment antagonism that's fueling
being fueled precisely from that awareness.
Now, to get back to your question about, uh,
how these different ideologies both on the
left or the right, respond or, or react to
that I think in, in very different ways.
There's no doubt right now, at least in my
mind, that, uh, many of the ideologies on
the y on the right, particularly ideologies
that are driven by nationalism, uh, and, uh,
white nationalism in particular are ideologies
that are self-consciously celebrating, uh,
a, uh, rejection of, um, what we might have
called rational authority authority.
Uh, that's part of what's fueling, uh, some
of the enthusiasm I think that we see from,
from particular advocates of that ideology
online.
The thought is, uh, and we, we see it, I think
an indeed by the inhabitant of the White House.
I mean, if you want to talk about arrogance,
it seems like, uh, exhibit number one of course
is Donald Trump, a man who after all has been
known to say that he's the humblest person
that he knows.
Uh, look, I think it's not, so it's not, I
think it has surprised most of the, your listeners
that, uh, that white nationalism is a view
as a view according to which, you know, uh,
whites are superior.
Uh, they, uh, the, uh, whites intrinsically
know more, are better people.
That sort of, uh, nonsense.
That's clearly an attitude that is symbolized
by or in, in embodies as type of arrogance
that I had been discussing.
And I think that the degree to which that's
continues to be propagated, uh, is the degree
to which we're going to see an increase, uh,
increase in sort of effective polarization
that we were talking about before.
On the other hand, I also want to point out
that, look, it's, uh, if you want to look
up intellectually arrogant in the dictionary,
you're probably gonna find a picture of a
face very much like mine.
I mean, I'm out.
I'm a white male, liberal, Progressive College
professor, uh, to do a lot of people in the
country.
You know, I, I embody intellectual arrogance
and I imagine some of the people listening
have probably been thinking that.
Fair enough.
I think it's important that progressors realize
that we are not immune to implicit bias.
We are not immune to the sort of problems
that are inherent in human psychology that
afflict the rest of mankind, so to speak.
Uh, progressive's I think we, and I am, I
have been guilty of this and some of your
listeners might think I've been guilty of
this already and this is that you can fall
into thinking that, uh, well, uh, conservatives,
you know, they're all like, uh, they all,
they all fall into the same buckets.
Uh, they all are the ones that have prejudice
and bias and we are the, we are the tribe
of reason and rationale and we are free of
those things.
That's a mistake.
It is falling into the same type of tribal
arrogance that were there.
You know, I, for 1:00 AM trying to combat,
so I will, um, frequently, somewhat frequently
get phone calls from viewers who will say,
Hey, David, you know, a couple years ago I
fell into an alt-right sort of echo chamber.
I was watching some gaming thing on youtube,
which led me to Stefan Molyneux and then Ben
Shapiro.
And then, Whoa, okay.
What they, they described the path in and
they say they, I bought into it completely.
And then the algorithm showed me, uh, a left
wing Gamer, which brought me to you and to,
you know, they'll name other people that do
what I do.
And now I'm out.
I'm out.
I've, I've sort of been deprogrammed from
that.
Uh, and of course my initial reaction is,
okay, that's the outcome is a good one as
far as I see it.
But is there not a bigger problem here that
merely by clicking around on youtube, you
were first pulled to the extreme, right?
And then merely by chance you became pushed
to the extreme left too.
I hear the, uh, way too malleable nature of
so many people's thinking and I'm curious
what your reaction is to those stories of
radicalization and de Radicalization, which
even if we like the way that the outcome went
to me signal a sort of problem plot, problematic,
deeper problem.
That's a really interesting point.
Uh, like you, of course I celebrate people
becoming de radicalized.
Yes, entirely from violent nationalist ideology
is, but I also agree that what that sort of
anecdote or story illustrates is the passiveness
by which most of you know the pass away in
which most of us seem to know nowadays.
Much of what we know we Google now is right.
I was talking about earlier, that's how most
people today receive most of their social,
their information.
And while again, that's, that can be really
super useful.
I Google know all day every day.
Um, it's also I think changing the way we
interface with information and how we critically
evaluate it.
I think that one of the things that, one of
the things that I, I talk about in the book
is some lessons from some very ancient, uh,
philosophical figures, including going back
all the way to Socrates.
Socrates.
One of the things that's really interesting
about the license you can get gleaned from
the end of his life is that he was somebody
who was interested in questioning, uh, both
authority and, and himself.
He said, well, you know, one of the things
that I really, the only thing I really can
say I know is that I don't know very much.
And he was keen of course, to sort of bring
down the people who claim that they know,
uh, quite a bit about things.
And he was like that he some a pleasure clearly.
And in, in getting them to admit that they
didn't know as much as I did and that's great.
But he also wanted us to focus on our own
attitudes.
And he thought that in order to do that you
needed to get outside on the street literally
and start talking to people to start having
conversations.
I think there's something to be said with
that attitude.
Not so much as that you can't talk people
to people online like we're doing right now.
That's perfectly, I think Socratic what, uh,
Socrates I think was really pushing us there
was to think of ourselves not as passive,
just shockers of information, but as, uh,
active inquirers people who get out and try
to, you know, read, engage, talk to one another
and question, question assumptions.
And as I said, continue to question your in
yourself and your own, your own biases and
prejudices that you might not have been aware
that you actually have
a very, very good advice for sure.
And if only I was taking place, if only it
was easier to make that the reality based
on how a lot of these online platforms are,
are deliberately configured to, to really
generate the opposite.
Um, we've been speaking with Michael Lynch
who's author of the new book.
No, it all society,
truth and arrogance in political culture.
Michael, really a pleasure having you on today.
Thanks so much.
It was great.